ouais décryptage tout de suite avec
bruno daroux bonjour bruno
jour du dombass de l'est ukrainien et en
particulier de cette ville c'est vers au
dos nièce cas un symbole une ville
stratégique aussi pour les russes que
volodymyr zelensky redoutent de ne voir
anéanti un peu à l'image de mario pour
rien de le voir oui absolument ça vient
d'introduire l'instant mais il faut bien
comprendre que cette ville de sciez
verre d'eau n'y est ce qu'un qui est
donc situé de manière stratégique dans
le donbass est absolument essentiel pour
les russes s'ils veulent on va peut-être
le voir sur la carte s'ils veulent
vraiment terminer leur conquête du
dombass parce que tout simplement et
bien cette ville en fête à leur
permettrait d'avoir voilà tout ce qui
leur manque là pour achever parachever
leur conquête du nom basse d'où la
violence des combats d'où la stratégie
des russes qui ressemble beaucoup à
celle d'ailleurs qui était utilisée lors
de la deuxième guerre mondiale ce que
les russes appellent la stratégie du
chaudron c'est à dire que il il bombarde
un stade un déluge d'artillerie
non-stop notamment ses batteries multi
roquettes en quelque sorte qu'ils
n'arrêtent pas de bombarder la ville ils
encerclent et puis ils attendent que les
habitants se rendent que les combattants
soit se rendre soit soit tué c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait pour marioupol c'est
effectivement ce qu'il veut ce qu'il
veut le faire pour hausser verrou
donetsk mais encore une fois cette ville
leur permettrait véritablement de 2,2
progressé d'où évidemment côté ukrainien
un appel au secours en disant là pour
l'instant les russes ont mis le paquet
en quelque sorte donc nous avons besoin
d'équipements nous avons besoin de plus
d'armes lourdes notamment de ses
batteries de roquettes sinon
effectivement la situation est
extrêmement difficile un mot aussi
peut-être sur cette crise alimentaire
qui ce qui se profile l'ukraine grenier
à blé utile de le rappeler on a beaucoup
parlé des pays du maghreb fortement
dépendants le sujet du jour c'est
londres les britanniques qui accuse
aujourd'hui moscou de faire du chantage
oui absolument la ministre britannique
des affaires étrangères liste run
estime que la russie en fête prend en
otage le monde a en utilisant ses larmes
alimentaires notamment des céréales
ukrainienne alors la lumière poutine lui
vient de se féliciter que côté céréales
russes et bien les exportations russes
continuent à bien se porter mais
évidemment depuis depuis le début de
l'invasion on sait que les ports de
marioupol mêmes d'odessa même si c'est
pas tomber aux mains des russes sont
bloquées c'est à dire c'était à partir
de ses ports de la mer noire que
l'ukraine exporter ses céréales
donc voyez qu'il ya une sorte de blocus
maritime qui empêche pour le moment ses
exportations au total il ya 20 millions
de tonnes de céréales ukrainienne qui
sont dans leurs silos qui sont stockés
dans ses ports et qui ne peuvent pas
aller alimenter d'état de pays notamment
évident au proche orient en afrique et
même en asie donc la ministre
britannique dit moscou est en train
d'utiliser cette arme alimentaire la
turquie essaie de de faire négocier
russe et ukrainien pour permettre sous
contrôle sur l'exportation de céréales
vers le détroit du bosphore là mais ces
négociations sont en cours et la russie
a dit a fait comprendre que elle était
prête peut-être un compromis sur
l'exportation des céréales ukrainienne
s'il y avait une levée en partie à des
sanctions occidentales ce à quoi
évidemment à les occidentaux pour le
moment ne sont pas très lointain de
chantage utilisé par les britanniques
merci beaucoup bruno pour le décryptage